did you guys know that mighty morphin
power rangers has a comic book
and it's amazing it's so cool they have
like this character named lord drakken
and like there is dude this story man
man this this man let me tell you
something it is it's good man it's it's
really really good okay mighty morphin
power rangers i grew up on mighty
morphin power rangers
and and i will say until the end of time
that green with envy is the best
little mini series in the power rangers
tv show ever
right like literally the green ranger
beat the crap out of all the other power
rangers here's the whole thing behind
this right all this really focuses on
tommy at least this this first video
that we're doing here right focus on the
green ranger this focus is on tommy
right so here's a crazy i mean there is
an actual there's a much bigger plot
going on behind behind this whole thing
but
this is kind of like a bit of a view or
or almost kind of a concept or an idea
that if tommy stayed under the spell of
rita repulsa when he was originally
introduced as the green ranger
that he would have done exactly what we
saw him do with green green with envy he
would have crushed the power rangers
rightfully so because he's the green
ranger and all the power rangers suck
compared to the green ranger so like we
we would have seen that happen right and
that's kind of what you see play out
here but what you end up doing is
actually kind of
jumping to reality in the moment now
this immediately follows i wouldn't say
immediately i'd say within like a
time period right it's like a few weeks
essentially but it basically follows the
whole idea of tommy
basically being freed from the influence
of rita repulsa and then being inducted
full
on into the power rangers and so you
kind of have him hanging out with jason
right which makes sense right jason and
tommy were like
the two guys like we kind of know what's
going on with these with these two dudes
but
one of the things that kind of goes on
here is that in the aftermath
of rita's involvement with tommy that
tommy gets these hallucinations with
rita repulsa where she just kind of pops
up and she'll just sort of influence him
or talk to him right almost kind of tear
him down
and that's a kind of mainstay of the
character right of
tommy himself is that he's always
dealing with this idea from like these
reader repulsive visions that like she's
telling him like you're not good enough
right without me you'll never really be
a good ranger
right you'll never be up to your your
full potential or anything along those
lines it really is like all of a
self-doubt kind of given form in rita
repulsa and so following that what you
actually end up getting you know while
they have their their school stuff you
know whatever nobody cares about the
power rangers when they were in school
right nobody cares i remember watching
that show and it was like okay now we're
going to switch over to the mighty
morphin power rangers
when they're in school like they're in
class and they're hanging out and doing
math and i was like i don't care
i want to see them fight like the
putties man like action boy now
action girl now it was a cool song from
a terrible movie but the whole thing
about this
is that you kind of have this moment
where they all basically band together
right it's morphing time
you guys know the whole thing and they
kind of jump in the fray against like
this massive monster that's basically
just ripping the place up and what you
end up getting is it's kind of this cool
moment where you
have like the the dragon zord who's
called in you've got the other zords who
call in they form into the megazord
the power rangers kind of do their thing
right the big caveat to this
is that while all that's happening tommy
zord is not functioning the way that
it's supposed to it's not responding to
his commands which is a huge deal
right like when you've literally got a
monster that's the size of a skyscraper
just ripping a town apart
and you need like all the rangers to
respond to it they've all got to be able
to operate at peak efficiency
and it's one of these things where like
the weak link in the chain
will lead to the ruin of all and so
that's when things really kind of become
hairy and they start asking questions
what's going on with tommy and the
initial response here from tommy is well
my dragons were just froze right i don't
know what's going on it's got to be some
kind of a glitch or something along
those lines billy or alpha 5 or whoever
it is somebody take a look at it let me
know what's going on
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
zordon chimes in and says okay
but like it doesn't necessarily work
that way right that when it comes to the
zords that you guys wield that the zords
really kind of require a bit of
involvement on your behalf they have to
be able to trust you now zordon kind of
chimes in and he actually brings into
this this this whole thing
if you guys recall in the original
series and in mighty morphin power
rangers the original tv show back in the
day that there wasn't a whole lot known
about the green ranger right the green
ranger coin the the the whole thing that
gave tommy's powers that it was
essentially something that was almost
unique to rita repulsa and zordon didn't
have a lot of knowledge about it her
involvement with the dragon's lord is
extensive and it's one of the things
that he says but for the most part he
can't really
offer a lot of options here it'd be
different if it was the red ranger or
the blue ranger or the yellow ranger or
or the pink ranger or the
even the black ranger it'd be different
if that was the case because zordon
could have a lot more influence there
because you know you guys know the whole
thing between zordon and the rangers but
when it comes to the green ranger
there's as many
unanswered questions as there are
answered questions and so not having a
full totality of the understanding of
what's going on here really presents a
few complications
the other part to this is that rita is
constantly trying to find a way to sort
of expand her power
but one of the things that's going on
here with this with really
this meeting between rita repulsa and
scorpina is scorpina had kind of been
set on a mission by rita and what you
kind of have here
is what's called a chaos crystal and so
what she's basically done here is
acquired a crystal for reader repulsor
that's something i want you guys to keep
in the back of your head because that's
incredibly important but from there you
basically jump to bulk and skull what
you kind of have here is really the
statement that's offered by
jason with regards to like people's
perception of the green ranger
and it's one of these things where it's
essentially known at this point the
green rangers single-handedly
dismantled the other rangers and now
that he's fighting alongside them
there's a lot of concern and a lot of
worry like
should we be worried about a former
villain turned hero who's fighting
alongside the rangers is it a ruse
something along those lines and the
response that jason kind of offers here
again sort of keeping his identity as a
ranger secret is well if the rangers
trust him we should trust him too
uh it's kind of an interesting thing
because what you're gonna notice going
on here is that in a lot of ways
there's a lot of distrust when it comes
to tommy that you even have these kind
of discussions that are going on
among the other rangers when tommy's not
there which is i mean
can we really trust him right i mean
this guy was seemingly picked out of
nowhere by
rita repulsa dropped into our laps beat
us within an
inch of our lives destroyed pretty much
the entire base of zordon and alpha 5.
like literally if it hadn't been for
this guy we never would have really
known we could be defeated you know what
i mean like like you guys remember that
you guys remember agreeing with envy
right i mean he just he trashed him he
trashed the rangers
it was a great it was the coolest thing
but that's kind of the question they're
left asking here right like
this guy was a henchman of rita repulsa
can we really trust him because we still
don't really know anything about him
like we still don't really know and
that's one of the kind of
kind of conversations that happens
between zack and jason even if zack is
just kind of like hey man like did you
really believe the stuff that you were
telling like bulk and skull on that he's
like what are you talking about he's
like i mean this idea that like zordon
never even really
asked us how we felt about bringing
tommy on board he just brought him on
board as a ranger but in all honesty and
that's one of the things where jason
kind of just
deviates to the wisdom of zordon it's
almost x-men-esque in that way right
like cyclops inherent belief that xavier
knows what he's doing and he's always
right
turned out to be wrong and that's why
cyclops defected it's kind of the same
way when you have like jason and zorno
right that jason trusts zordon he trusts
the experience and the wisdom of zordon
and he kind of leans into that and says
well zordon didn't really know anything
about us
right we were teenage kids with attitude
right that's basically what we were
and he trusted that we could be
effective as rangers and so why can't we
trust him when it comes to tommy but
jason has reservations man and so what
you end up doing is kind of switching to
this this bit of a moment here where you
have like all these putties and like
this torn worn down city a giant monster
just
leveling everything in sight just
ripping it all to pieces and so you have
tommy who's tasked with this uh this
role to basically take these people to
safety right these innocent individuals
to safety the problem is that as he does
that he ends up leading them down
what is in effect a trap right it's
essentially this kind of hallway or this
this corridor where they're just
surrounded by putties
while all that's going on he's got rita
repulsa whispering in her in his ear
telling him things right it won't be
enough it's never enough right like like
you you know you led these people to
this place you know you failed when they
counted on you like all that kind of
stuff like you're never going to be an
effective ranger only for us to find out
is a training simulator now this
is incredibly cool right because at this
point i would even say
zordon is a little weary about tommy but
the thing about this is that the
training simulators are not really just
for tommy right it's not one of these
things where it's like hey man
we don't really trust you dude so like
from now on you're just gonna be hanging
out
in the simulator and and we'll just see
how you respond instead the simulator is
designed to test them as rangers and to
really kind of
force them into these positions where
they have to face mortality
and this particular simulation focus on
the idea of a no-win situation right
it's the it's the kobayashi maru for the
uh for the mighty morphin power rangers
right a no-win scenario instead of tommy
hacking the system and cheating
[Laughter]
like captain kirk did in star trek uh he
he chose what he thought was the best
decision the reality is that had he
chosen the other road he actually would
have led them directly into the face of
the monster but
the whole gist of this and the reason
why it's so important is because there
are times when as a ranger you are going
to have to face certain defeat
right you are going to have to face the
fact that you might die and the the
whole idea behind the simulator is to
one understand you're not gonna make the
perfect choice every single time
and two when that happens you're gonna
have to be able to face the consequences
of it you're gonna have to deal with it
as best you can
it was really a moral fortitude test and
really a kind of courage test
for tommy what was he gonna do in the
face of disaster was he just gonna panic
and cry
was he gonna just you know keep fighting
for as long as he could
and he responded and seemingly the best
way he could the other part of that is
you end up having trini and billy who
really just kind of analyzed the whole
thing right they analyze the dragon
sword to figure out what's going on and
all that kind of good stuff so not a
whole lot going there
billy does his usual thing where he's
like i don't know if i'm really cut out
to be a ranger you know
people don't really like me all that
much you know and it's like billy get it
together man like you're a ranger dude
come on like i mean
see i personally couldn't be a power
ranger man because i'd be using that to
get laid like all the time i'd be i'd
just like show up my power ranger gear
and just like hey girl
the funny thing about this is that once
tommy gets back to his place he's
immediately met by the arrival of
scorpina now that's kind of
the crazy thing here is because tommy
makes the right move just like that and
actually teleports scorpina away now
this is one of the big issues that tommy
deals with here and the reason why is
because as soon as he and scorpino are
in this field by
by themselves he morphs into the green
ranger and then goes to fight scorpina
notice here he does not contact the
other rangers and that's a big
problem because whenever it is that
you're a power ranger you're inherently
a team right like you you fight as a
team
you do your thing you like you hang out
as a team that's one of the things that
was kind of built and really established
when it came to the rangers i mean they
did
everything together right like they ate
lunch together it was maybe the cool
kids table i don't really know
right but like they they ate their food
together they hung out together they
would like go shopping and stuff like
that together and even if it wasn't like
the whole group
it'd be like kimberly and trini right or
like jason and zach
or like billy jason and zach or
something along those lines but like
they would all go and do stuff seemingly
in some form or fashion as a team
tommy is very much isolated and very
much a loner and that's a very important
thing for his character because all he
really knows
in relation to the rangers is for the
most part betrayal right i mean granted
he was being manipulated and controlled
by rita repulsa at the time but the
reality of this
is that the rangers still don't fully
trust him and so it is kind of
on him to try to demonstrate that he is
a trustworthy individual and doing
things like this
right like just jumping into a fight
with one of rita's really one of her
most dangerous henchmen is a pretty big
thing when you're not calling the other
rangers in right
i can deal with it on my own i don't
need you guys and while there is
something to be said about having the
courage to
to face your your struggles on your own
there's a big difference between doing
it because you have to
and doing it because you choose to and
tommy is choosing to ignore his
teammates here
and do this on his own and that's kind
of the crazy thing is because you end up
having this great big huge thing where
like putties are called in
and they end up facing off against all
the putties and so on and so forth but
then rita basically chimes in you kind
of jump over to her for a second and the
idea of scorpina being here is twofold
first and foremost if at all possible
get the power coin away from tommy right
like get it from him and then bring it
back to rita that's the best alternative
that's like the the main mission here
but
shy of being able to do that get tommy
to expend as much of his energy as
possible
because the crystal that rita has is
powered by it like literally as he
fights
it powers the crystal and that's kind of
the subversive motive here right it's
the one thing that's kind of not being
made aware of right i mean you have
scorpion who's like give me the power
coin
that kind of thing but she's not really
saying like keep on fighting because
then i'll you know you'll expend your
energy
and then we'll be able to power some
crystal that we made somewhere but the
rest of the rangers
seemingly jump in here right yeah you
have these other rangers who kind of
jump in right the red ranger the the
pink ranger right they all just kind of
jump in you know as best they can and
it's cool to see them all kind of
teaming up but at the end of the day
like rita is still
chiming in to tommy right she's still
talking to tommy still being kind of
subversive
and and offering these words that really
sort of tear them down that kind of a
thing the other question that kind of
comes here
really comes from the other rangers is
why didn't you get a hold of us and the
whole thing about tommy is no i was like
i was blindsided okay like she showed up
in my house what was i gonna do like i
just teleported her away and that was
basically it but again
the role of the rangers is to be able to
think fast to be able to analyze the
situation and leave emotion out of it
and tommy basically seems to lack that
ability that's really what seems to be
going on here he's very much a loner
very much doing his own thing he's not
really used to operating as a team and
it's showing itself
here and so the result of all this is
that as as rita keeps chiming in
and really kind of bothering tommy even
while he's there with the rest of the
rangers and their base of operations
then ultimately it gets the better of
him and he seemingly just passes out and
so what he ends up having here at least
what he ends up experiencing
are almost kind of like these visions
and hallucinations now some of these
are are really more like premonitions
more so than hallucinations or anything
else but the thing about this
is that once tommy kind of comes to the
dream that he'd had
is that he'd basically been taken home
by the rangers and dropped off at his
house and his mom's like oh you know
it's okay and it's cool you have such
great friends and power rangers even
wow and then it kind of blows blows
tommy away it's like you're not supposed
to know that right you're not supposed
to know and then of course she rips her
face off and it turns off as it turns
out it's rita repulsa who's still
screwing with tommy's head and that's
kind of the crazy thing about that is
because you jump to rita herself
and that's when she says we really kind
of get this explanation where it's while
tommy's not necessarily under her direct
spell
that seemingly the powers he possesses
come from rita but by whatever manner
and whatever means there's still a
bridge there and so she's seemingly
still able to manipulate and to kind of
influence tommy now again a lot of that
is just for the idea of
always trying to get him to come back
always trying to reel tommy back in
again but the important thing here is
she she basically kind of tells scorpina
the whole idea
is that as tommy continued to fight
against you and against whoever it is
that he's facing off against now
the green chaos energy that he emits
will basically
fuel this crystal and at the end of the
day we'll be able to open a portal which
is exactly what they've been shooting
for and there's a reason why they're
looking to open this portal because it's
a great concept it's a great idea but
what they end up doing here is in order
to
force tommy to expend even more energy
as much as they possibly
can they come up with this idea to
basically create what is in effect
a forged dagger or forged key that will
allow them to use the dragonzord not
only that you have trini who actually
runs a kind of mental scan on tommy the
problem is that
in the middle of this mental scan
suddenly like he experiences this vision
when the dragon zord goes nuts and just
destroys the entirety of their their
base of operations and everything right
like there's nothing they can do like it
all just gets ripped apart
the the rangers and the whole nine yards
and then suddenly tommy comes too right
like tommy just wakes up and that's kind
of the crazy thing is because when trini
goes to to check the
energy scan of uh of tommy she comes to
the realization
something else is going on and so what
ends up happening is she actually calls
all the rangers back to their base
operations and then she presents it with
the information right and she says okay
so this is when jason got his body
scanned right his mind and body scan
essentially his energy signature right a
power scan as they call it this is what
he looks like right this is what tommy
looks like
somebody is messing with tommy's powers
somebody is
influencing tommy and they again they
don't know that rita is the one who's
doing this
and so when the question's like okay
like can it be somebody like rita like
can somebody be doing this i mean that's
the immediate thought right she's the
one that basically created him as the as
the green ranger why wouldn't she be the
one who's involved and when they kind of
ask him like hey man like
have you been in contact with rita is
that is that kind of what's going on man
tommy spills the beans and says
initially it started off as flashes
right in the corner of my eye i'd see a
blip of rita repulsa over there or over
there or i might see her off in the
distance or something like that
but the more things went on the more i
began to see her regularly and then the
more i began to experience her talking
to me
tearing me down telling me all these
things basically taking all these
feelings that i had about myself and
bringing them into the surface
and really settling him up and forcing
him really kind of stripping away the
confidence that he has
and what he's capable of now when the
most obvious question is asked
why didn't you tell us the response of
tommy is i was trying to handle it but
this is a really important thing to
understand here
one of the big differences between tommy
and the other rangers is all the other
rangers
quote unquote grew up with this for lack
of a better word they didn't really grow
up together in the traditional sense but
it's really more the thing like they all
became
rangers at the same time so they were
discovering their powers and it really
forced them to bond in a way
that tommy just hasn't done yet right i
mean they were learning what their
ranger powers were
they've got their own home lives their
own struggles and they learned quite
quickly that in order to operate at peak
efficiency as the power rangers they had
to be in unison right mind body and
spirit they had to operate in that way
and so a lot of what would normally be
those social hierarchies that exist
among you know high school kids
a lot of those things that would be
those kind of mental barriers that sort
of
keep them from revealing those parts of
themselves how they feel or
their struggles or family lives those
were eliminated very fast and so there
was a very strong closeness that was
built between
all the other members of the power
rangers tommy is just here and so now
that they don't really trust him because
when they first met him he just trashed
them all rightfully so because the green
ranger is better than all the other
power rangers when that happened
it built a lot of mistrust you know like
it so much has happened
so fast that there really hasn't been a
chance for anybody to kind of catch
their breath
and figure out what's going on not only
that you've also got uh scorpina who
manages to use the forged dagger to
actually take control of the dragon zord
and then start like
trashing the town right like just
ripping everything up now the other
rangers respond and actually start
dragging it back into the water but
that's when like another monster is
created by rita which offers as a
distraction to basically keep the power
rangers from focusing on the dragon's
word
enter tommy in one of his coolest
moments here but what you end up getting
is this whole situation where tommy
who's more or less being kept away from
the other rangers and being kept back in
the base of operations kind of watching
everything unfold
is doing so because you know for the
most part as he's facing these
hallucinations they consistently get the
better of him and so you have this
really great moment where this this kind
of personality of rita repulsa as is
influencing him and saying things like
they were always going to find out you
can only fake it for so long that you're
a normal person but in the end you're no
hero right you're not a hero like the
other power rangers you're the villain
you're the bad guy you're the you're the
wolf in sheep's clothing
right like that's it like you're you are
never going to be anything great
and ultimately tommy overcomes it and
says no like i used to believe you were
real
i used to think that you were actually
tangible but no you just all my self
doubt right you're all the self doubt
that i have my insecurity this wrapped
up through all my dragon powers
like you are everything that i dislike
about myself
but in the end you're still just me this
is tommy coming to grips with himself
and if only it were so easy for us as
people to see some tangible
manifestation
of every negative emotion we have about
ourselves and then overcome it so easily
right if only that were the case
life would be so much easier if only was
possible for us to just have some
you know physical version we could just
pummel but tommy does and as he comes to
terms with that and as he starts to
realize no
right i am capable of being a hero i was
under re to repulse a spell when i did
all these terrible things but what the
rangers need right now is not some guy
who's struggling with self-doubt they
don't need some guy who lacks confidence
in his capabilities
they need the green ranger they need a
guy who's going to defy all the odds and
even break the rules if it means saving
their life and that's what happens with
zordon zordon's like no right we can't
really trust that you're you've gotten
past these hallucinations and the
response to tommy is dude i don't care
man
like i don't really care about your
stupid rules you blue floating head like
i don't really care about that it's
morphing time right he's
dude man man i'm sorry i'm so excited
people it is an exciting story right
it's it's cool it's
this it's a really cool moment here
right guy jumps up like
grabs us grabs his dagger man starts
that's the thing man let me tell you
something in all the years when i was
watching power rangers that's when you
knew [ __ ] was about to pop off
right like it's just like it's like i
don't like you don't even see you don't
even know tommy's there right it's just
like things are popping off and things
are getting kind of nuts you know
oh tommy's coming man like tommy's going
to save the day you know and like here
comes the dragon sword and the day gets
saved it was always kind of a cool thing
right and so literally he basically
seizes control of his dragon zord again
he basically fights off scorpina right
manages to defeat her again
expelling a little bit more energy here
but once he basically comes out on top
and once he's able to basically destroy
the uh the the fake dagger that she has
and then replace it with his real one
then that gives him control of his
dragon's word again right and between
the two of them and the megazord you
know defeating the giant monster then
that's basically
it right the problem is once they get
back into the base of operations
jason lets tommy have it right he's just
like
i don't know how much more clear i could
have been i appreciate that you wanted
to just break the rules and go out into
the field and save us from this imminent
danger i really do appreciate that but
understand
we can't trust you man like we don't
like one
like you tried to destroy us when you
were under the spell of rita and you
almost
did and then now that you're not under
the spell of rita you are thrown onto
the power rangers team
we don't even have a choice of whether
you were going to be here or not then
you were hallucinating and you were
seeing [ __ ]
like what we can't there's nothing about
you that we can trust right now but at
the end of the day
he's just kind of like no right like
that's it like this is this is this is
it right i mean either you have me here
or you don't but i'm not playing this
game
of like trying to bounce between your
rules and your standards and all that
kind of stuff that's not how this works
man
i just saved your lies so if you guys
have a problem with that
then like you end up having this kind of
situation where zach gives him you know
ends up giving him grief and he's just
kind of like you know when he's like
dude like let go of me he's like what
are you gonna do you're gonna go all
evil green ranger and that's enough
right there right that's enough of it
right there
because the whole time they're there
scorpion is tied to a chair she's
watching all this unfold and then
something catches her eye
as tommy gets more and more angry as he
keeps going
on and on and on and even starts to get
into a fight with jason
the crystal in that dagger is glowing
right it's glowing
it's charging up it's powering up and
ultimately when tommy goes
in for it goes into attack jason that's
all it needs right like the thing is
fully charged
literally a portal rips open and just
blows out the side
of the entire base of operations and in
what is probably
the entrance of the greatest character
ever in the history of power rangers in
the history of the whole power rangers
mythos a black dragon zord appears right
and it's just like what's going on power
rangers i've been looking forward to
destroying
all of you for a long long time
who wants to go first well that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching let me
know if you want to see more and i will
catch you all later
peace